أول رقصة غير عادية للعروسين في
غرفة المستشفى
شاهدوا أكثر من مليون مرة فيروسية على الإنترنت
لأن العروس البالغة من العمر 23 عامًا
تتعافى من بتر كلتا ساقيها
، لقد مر شهر تقريبًا منذ أن
داس Oksana Balandina على لغم أرضي
في مسقط رأسها في ليسي تشانسك.
كان الزوج المنتصر الجديد
معًا منذ أن كانا مراهقين ، ولهما
طفلان معًا ، كان الزواج
دائمًا في خططهم يومًا ما ،
ولكن بعد أن قرر المنتصر في الانفجار أن هذا
اليوم قد
تأخر عن موعده ، تزوج الزوجان في حفل مدني
وعادا إلى غرفتهما في المستشفى من أجل ارتجال
أجنبي ، التقط الفيديو من قبل صديق
نشره عبر الإنترنت
، تمت مشاركته الآن وإعادة نشره في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، وستحتاج إلى مزيد من القوة مع
العلاج الحالي في العيش ، حيث
يقيم أطفالهم مع أجدادهم في
جميع أنحاء البلاد من أجل مستقبلهم المنظور.
هل كان لأطفالك
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
في غضون أيام قليلة سيأخذ المنتصر أوكسانا إلى
ألمانيا ليكون لائقًا  تيد للأطراف الاصطناعية
قريبًا ، تأمل أن تسير
في الممر الذي يخططون فيه بالفعل
لحضور حفل زفاف رسمي في الكنيسة مع جميع
أصدقائهم وعائلاتهم حتى ذلك الحين يأملون
أن يأخذ الناس درسًا صغيرًا من
قصتهم
يكتشفون ماكلين سي إن ليفيف أوكرانيا